(upbeat organ music)
- Welcome to a Conversation with History,
I'm Harry Kreisler of the Institute
of International Studies.
Our guest today is James O. Freedman,
who is the president
of the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences, from 1987 to 2000,
he was president of Dartmouth College,
and from 1982 to 1987, the president
of the University of Iowa.
His publications include
Crisis and Legitimacy:
The Administrative Process
and American Government,
and Idealism and the Role of Education.
Mr. Freedman, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you very much.
- You write in your book,
Idealism and Liberal Education,
which I will show here, you say,
sometimes lives do seem
to be framed by a theme,
and you pose as an important question
to identify the forces
that created and shaped
that defining theme, so I think it's fair
for me to first ask you, what has been
the defining theme of your life?
- Well, that's a good question.
I think back to when I was,
probably in high school,
and one of the books we were asked to read
was Macaulay's essay on
Johnson, a short essay,
and we were told to go home one night
and to find the sentence in that essay
that best capsulized the theme
of Samuel Johnson's life,
and I've always remembered that sentence,
because Macaulay's
sentence that is the pivot
is that the force of his mind
overcame all impediments.
So when I look at lives, including my own,
I do try to think about
what the themes were.
I think, in my life, there've
really been two themes.
The first has been the
question of education.
I fell in love with
education as a young person.
I loved to read, I loved to go to school,
I didn't wanna leave college,
I didn't wanna leave law school.
That's certainly one of the themes,
and I think the other theme has to do with
whatever influences there
were on me in growing up
in a Jewish home in a
small New Hampshire town,
with a very small Jewish population.
And there's, of course, a very common,
a really mundane theme
of Jewish kid striving
to make their place in American society.
- And how did your parents
shape you in this regard?
- Well, I think, my father
was a high school teacher,
he taught junior year in high school.
I think they shaped me
primarily by reading.
We always had books in the
house, always had magazines.
For my father, the life of
literature was wonderful.
He, because of the way
high schools bought books,
you tended to teach the same book
as long as they had 40 copies
year after year after year,
and he taught every year
Idylls of the King by Tennyson,
he taught Macbeth, he taught
The House of Seven Gables
by Hawthorne, and he was
in love with those books,
and he did not get bored
or tired, year after year,
in teaching them.
- Did you have any teachers
as a young person that
really influenced you,
talking now about high school, not later?
- I can't say in high
school, there were teachers
whom I thought were very
good, and whom I liked,
but I was still, I wasn't a
reader yet in high school,
I was too interested in the
things young adolescent kids do,
but reading wasn't one of them.
I really didn't start to
read in a serious way till,
in a way that, in a loving
way, until I got to college.
- And talk a little about your mother
and her input into the
shaping of your character.
- Well, my mother, I think,
had a profound input.
She was the daughter of immigrants,
she grew up in New York, she
never had the opportunity,
as women usually didn't in those days,
to go to college, but she was
profoundly ambitious for me.
There was nothing too
high for me to aim at.
She, I think it was her ambition,
and my father's kind of love of literature
and things intellectual,
that kind of merged
to fuel where my energies were put.
- And what about conversations
at the dinner table?
Was there a lot of the discussions
that go with Jewish idealism,
concerns about social justice?
- No, there wasn't.
I mean, I really, we were
not a heavily observant
Jewish family, my mother, indeed,
would not be observant at all.
Her parents, I suspect, were socialists
who'd come over from Europe.
Religion, to her, was indeed probably
the opiate of the masses,
if she could know that term.
My father cared, and I
was, of course, bar mitzvah
and we went to shul on the
high holidays and the like,
but I really wasn't aware until,
I would say just in the last 10 years
of what a profound effect it had on me
to be the only Jewish kid
in my class from K to eight,
and one of the two or three in a class
of 300 in high school.
I mean, it's only in recent
years that I've looked back
and seen how important being Jewish was,
how outside, how much
of an outsider I felt,
although at the time, I did not.
- And you, in one of your
essays, you actually talk about
Justices Frankfurter and Brandeis,
and the consequences of their Jewishness
for the way they viewed the world
and their concerns, actually,
and this outsider theme emerges in that.
- Well, that's right,
the theme of that essay,
in a sense, is that some Jews have wanted
to be insiders and some
Jews have preferred
to remain outsiders, and I don't know
that I had any conscious preference,
but I was probably an outsider
until, I would say, 10 years ago,
and it's in the last 10 years
that I have become, in my own mind,
very identified with Jewish causes.
I'm now very active in the
American Jewish Committee,
and I do, I'm on the board of Brandeis.
I care now, deeply, about Jewish causes
but I did not until I was
probably into my mid-50s.
- Do you think you've been influenced
by the focus on cultural identity
that is so much a part of
American pluralism today?
- No, I think I've really,
it's been, I think two things.
It's, first of all,
I've discovered the joy
and beauty of Judaism and
the threat that it is under
in a country, in the United States,
not principally, from anti-Semitism,
but from intermarriage, that the values
of the Jewish community
and of Jewish religion
seem to me very important, and I think,
we risk not being able to perpetuate them
if we don't identity as Jews.
I think the other thing is
that I really went through
my life without ever facing anti-Semitism,
and it's only in the last 10 years
that I've come to appreciate
how much my parents'
generation did suffer from that,
and I've come to be much
more conscious of that.
- Let's go back a minute,
'cause you touched on this,
but as I look at your
life and your writings,
it's really a story, as you said,
of understanding how to educate yourself,
how to create a community of education
and how to secure an
environment in which students
will be prepared for life.
So let's talk a little
about this love affair
that you have with books,
which I think is a phase,
in that you are a collector.
Tell us a little about books
and what they have meant
for you beyond just reading them.
- Well, there are, of
course, single books,
individual books that all
of us find at some point
in our life, and we read
once every two or three years
for the rest of our life,
and I have a half a dozen
of such books, but I have
loved collecting books.
And I don't know how
that relates to being,
as some people are, a collector
of stamps or of antique cars
or of pressed flowers or
what, but I have loved
collecting books, and I
have an elaborate scheme
of organization and codification,
and have something now on
the order of 6,000 books.
- Oh my goodness.
- Although, every two,
three, four years, I
sell a thousand of them
because I just don't have room.
And it's like giving up a child,
but I just don't have room.
And your interests change, and books
that interested you 30 years
ago interest you less today.
- What writers stand out in your mind?
I mean, there must be an enormous number
for someone like you,
but sort of key books,
pivotal books?
- Well, key books,
I would say Camus is one, and The Plague
would be the pivotal book,
Faulkner is of course one,
and gosh, anything of
Faulkner is wonderful.
I love the short stories of Faulkner.
I love Hawthorne, and I love, oh,
The Blithedale Romance even more
than I love Scarlet Letter,
both wonderful books.
I very much like V.S.
Naipaul, and I think his books
are just just brilliant books,
but there are many, the
authors could go on.
- And what, you say,
you write in your book,
books earn their claim on our lives
by their power to help us to think,
to care and to acquire standards
of judgment and appreciation.
So it's really a program of
continuous education, really?
I think it is, and the phrase,
books claim, make their
claim on that power,
all of us have read books
that we never quite forget.
I mean, I saw a reference a
day or two ago in some place
in the papers to Of Mice
and Men, the Steinbeck book,
and Lenny in there.
After you've read that book,
you never again can be quite as callous
as perhaps you once
were to people who are,
perhaps, a bit retarded,
perhaps a bit slow,
but are kindly and nice people.
It affects you, it affects everything
you look at after that.
- And it partly, the story,
the idea that moves you,
but it's also the use of
words, the use of language?
- Oh, sure it is.
I mean there's not a parent, I think,
who, if you read King
Lear in your adulthood,
doesn't ask himself lots
and lots of questions
of how did Lear go wrong
with his daughters.
And, gosh, the lines
from Lear that come out,
How sharper than a serpent's tooth
it is to have a thankless child.
I mean, the language is not beatable.
As an undergraduate, I had two
courses with Northrop Frye,
the great scholar of
so much of literature.
And he used to say that
an economy of words
in expressing a thought is
one of the great achievements.
And, of course, the
quintessential example is,
To be or not to be.
You probably can't
express that idea better
than that brief collection of words.
- You are a craftsman with the
word, as I read your essays.
- Thank you.
- Do you think that that comes from,
to use the metaphor you used yesterday,
the passing of the Jade, that
you have acquired a skill
with writing by reading so much?
- I don't know if it was that as much
as it was going to law school.
I think law school makes
you aware of words.
There was a famous episode, I'm not sure
that it's in the book, when Abe Fortas
was being nominated for the Supreme Court,
and he was asked a question
in the Judiciary Committee
about a phrase like due process of law,
and he couldn't answer it,
or he wouldn't answer it.
He didn't believe it wise to answer it,
and the senators kept pressing him.
Look, it's only a few
words, I mean, after all.
And Fortas replied and said,
"Sir, I have made my living with words,
"and I can tell you every
single word is tricky,
"and it's a well of meaning
"and you've got to be very careful."
So I think law school really made me
conscious of how to use
words, and it made me aware
that you need 10 drafts
of anything you write,
and it does get better.
You put the adjectives in
and then you take them out.
- So what is the most important thing
a student must know about writing?
That is, the patience, the perseverance,
the need for rewrite?
- All of those, but I think
most of all, the right word.
I mean, I, again and again
am puzzled in my own writing
by how to find the right adjective.
Did someone say something sharply
or bitterly, or quickly or glibly?
I mean, to find the right adverb,
I find enormously
challenging and difficult.
- You went to Harvard and
then to Yale Law School.
And I was struck, in reading
your autobiographical essay,
about, something changed in you
that made you more comfortable
with being a student.
What was that?
- Yeah, I've tried myself
to figure that out.
I, certainly, at Harvard did well enough,
but was not exceptional, a
good part of the Harvard years
were years of kinda
post-adolescent depression
and lack of certainty and groping around
for what life might offer.
I then worked for two years after college,
and by the time I went back to law school,
I think I was more mature
and there was something
about law school that was
just, to me, dazzling.
I just loved those professors.
I didn't want to leave after three years.
It was just a wonderful experience.
- And you were a journalist in between?
- I was a journalist in
between, that's right.
- And you suggested that that contributed
also to your giving?
- It may well have.
It certainly put me in closer touch
with public affairs and made me,
we're talking now at a local level,
city council, police
court, things of that sort.
But all of that made me think it would be
a good thing to be a lawyer.
- Now what at Yale, you encountered
and studied under one of the
two mentors in your life,
Alexander Bickel,
- Yes.
- Who was a professor of law.
Tell us his impact on
you and the educational
journey that you've taken.
- Well, Alex Bickel had
an enormous impact on me.
He is a man who was born in Bucharest,
came to this country at age 12,
became a brilliant student himself,
clerked for Justice Frankfurter.
He was just, in the classroom, electric.
Alex Bickel had a mind
of enormous originality.
He encouraged students to
engage him and debate him.
He was enormously generous.
He helped me when I wanted
to enter law teaching.
Alex Bickel was just, kind of
the most important teacher I ever had.
- And he taught you procedure, right,
was that, or many things?
- Well, constitutional law.
- Oh, constitutional law.
- He was a constitutional law person,
but he had views on
constitutional law which were
quite out of the received
conventional wisdom at the time,
and today, I think on sadly,
are hardly regarded at all.
I regard them highly, but history has
in a sense, passed by his views.
Maybe they'll come back someday.
- And what were those views?
- Well, he is very much a
person of judicial restraint.
- I see.
- Very much a person
of keeping the Supreme
Court out of federal courts,
generally, out of decisions
that oughta be made
by legislative and elected officials.
- Mm-hmm, so he would
have been much exasperated
by the recent election in Florida?
- Well, I think so, yes, I think so.
- He taught you, you say,
the morality of consent
and the procedures by which
public decisions are made?
- Yes, I mean, part of
what Bickel understood was
that society had to develop organically.
One of his great heroes was Edmund Burke.
And he admired Burke's sense of society
as a kind of a coral reef of beliefs
and views that have been accumulated
over many, many centuries.
And he really wanted society,
he wanted the Supreme Court to play a role
that generated widespread
consent, rather than just,
by edict, announce this
is what the law will be,
because he thought that didn't
have a chance of catching on,
that one really needed to generate
in society a general consent, and indeed,
that's what he thought,
I'm not sure whether
he thought Brown against the Board,
which declared segregation
unconstitutional,
was a wise decision in a scholarly sense,
but he was very pleased
with the Court saying,
We will do this, not immediately,
but with all deliberate speed,
to be done slowly, carefully, building up
a kind of a basis in society
for acceptance of it.
- And the man who argued that case,
Brown versus Board of Education
was Thurgood Marshall,
who you law clerked under.
- That's right.
- Actually later,
when he was appointed
to the Appellate Court
and then the Supreme Court.
- Indeed, Alex Bickel told me once,
he was a law clerk for Justice Frankfurter
when that case was argued, and he said
that Justice Marshall's argument
was the finest Supreme Court
argument he had ever heard.
- Tell us a little
about Thurgood Marshall.
- Well, there's a remarkable man, I think,
one of the great Americans,
and I think I say in the book,
I think that he has done
more for race relations
in this country than, perhaps,
any individual except for Abraham Lincoln.
That may be a bit of an overstatement,
but he should be near the top.
He's a remarkable man.
He was so different from
my law school professors,
who were, of course, very
scholarly and intellectual.
He, when I went to work for him right out
of law school was a practical man.
He wanted to know how trials worked,
and when errors were made,
allegedly, in lower courts,
I mean, he was looking at trial tactics,
he was looking at why they occurred.
He was much more a pragmatic man
than most law professors were,
and that added a very nice
dimension to my own growth.
- And he really carried the load
of all of the civil rights cases
that went through the courts, leading up
to Brown versus Board of
Education, which he also argued.
- He did indeed, and indeed,
not only carried the load,
as you indicate, carried it
both intellectually and physically.
The story of his life is a story of riding
in jalopies all across the
South, without air conditioning,
unable to stay in hotels,
unable to use facilities
in gas stations, I mean, a
really tough, hard existence.
And more than that, he carried the load
in the theory of how to go
to Brown against the Board.
Many people in the civil rights movement
disagreed with him, they
thought he would lose that case.
And if he lost it,
things would be set back
for another 50 years, that it was wiser
to go prove that separate
facilities weren't equal,
one by one, rather than try to get them
all declared unconstitutional.
- So he, in a way, had what you call,
quoting Emerson, a heroic mind.
- He clearly did, I mean, he was a person,
he had a sense of destiny,
and you could just,
occasionally, you meet
those in your friends.
You occasionally see it in students.
I mean, he knew from some very young age
that he was destined
to do important things,
I mean, he felt it, he
believed it, he wanted it.
And he did have a heroic mind.
And, I mean, it's interesting to me
that once Brown against
the Board was decided,
he had really achieved his destiny.
And that's when he began
to think of other things,
and of course, finally became a judge.
- In the Brown versus Board of Education,
we should note he used
Gunnar Myrdal's book
on The American Dilemma,
and that text had,
a key draftsman of that was Ralph Bunche.
- That's right.
- Who was another
distinguished Black American,
so both in their own ways
worked to bring down the
barriers of segregation.
- Well, that's right, Ralph Bunche
had a very difficult career
because he was black.
He was, I believe, the first black person
appointed a professor at Harvard,
but only served a year
or two and then went back
to activities outside the academy.
But that's exactly right,
Kenneth Clark was another one.
And of course, Kenneth Clark's experiments
with asking black children to choose
between white dolls and black dolls
was also cited by the court,
along with Gunnar Myrdal,
as support for the decision.
- In talking about, in one of your essays
comparing Martin Luther King,
Eudora Welty, Hugo Black, you're trying
to find the features that
exist in all of their lives,
and you conclude by saying,
They teach us the importance
of achieving a grip on our identity
and a sense of our own calling.
So let's take that as a
platform to move into your focus
on educating students, giving
them a liberal arts education.
What do you think that these heroes
and that kind of education can teach us
about our own lives and
how we should lead them?
- Well, what I think a liberal education,
at its best can do, is make
us say, You live but once.
You have, everyone has unusual abilities,
unique abilities, and
part of the satisfactions
of life come from
deploying those abilities
in the name of a great cause.
Martin Luther King is a good example.
I think when he was 26
years old in Montgomery,
he had no idea that he would find him,
that history would present him
with the opportunities it did,
but the point is he
seized the opportunities.
He saw that it was his destiny
because of his talents,
because he was a stranger
to the South at that
moment, not to the South,
to Montgomery, that he could do something.
I think the same is
true with Justice Black,
who was a conventional plaintiff's lawyer
and got into the Senate,
and suddenly became wedded
to a series of social
ideas about public policy
and of course on the Supreme Court.
When Justice Black got
to the Supreme Court,
all of his law clerks
report that the first day,
when they reported for work,
he handed them a copy of Tacitus and said,
"Take the first week and read this,
"because all of the evils
that Tacitus describes
"in the Roman Empire, of
what power does to corrupt,
"of how government seeks to
impose improperly on people,
"those are all in Tacitus and they're all
"what we're talking about today."
He informed himself with a larger view
of human nature and human conduct.
- And what about Eudora Welty,
who also is in that tract?
- What I like about Eudora Welty
is that there's a woman who still lives
in the house in which she grew up,
who rarely leaves Jackson, Mississippi.
You may know the essays
that were published
as One Writer's Beginning
that she delivered at Harvard.
In the last sentence, I
believe, of that volume
says something on the order,
A sheltered life can also be a daring one.
And she lived a sheltered, quiet life,
never married, but she
made the most of it.
She came to look at people
and to look deeply into people
and learn how to describe people,
and of course, became an
exquisite story writer.
- You, in talking about
a liberal arts education,
say the value of a liberal
education is on how it is made
to shape, refine and deepen
our sense of self and others.
You also talk about building
our private sense of self,
but relating that to the
building of a public self.
Talk a little about
that, what is the dynamic
between those two and
what is the requirement
in building each of those things?
- Well, you know, the public self
that we all show to the
world is obviously important.
An engagement in public life,
engagement in one's profession
and all those things
are obviously important.
But what I hope a liberal education does
is to make you ask
questions about yourself.
What is it that makes me happy?
What makes me a good person?
What would make me a better person?
Why is it so difficult to come to grips
with unhappiness and sadness?
Why is life so unfair to some people?
Those are the questions
that a liberal education,
that great literature, great essays,
do help you ask yourself,
and I think they make you
a wiser person because of that.
- What about the public side,
I mean, building that commitment?
Is it through the study of individuals
like Thurgood Marshall or what?
- I think that's one way.
I think there are
probably others, as well.
I mean, I've been struck
living in small towns
for much of my adulthood, Iowa City, Iowa,
Hanover, New Hampshire, at the extent
to which communities
depend upon participation.
If people don't run for the school board
or for selectman, if people
don't participate in PTAs,
if people don't write letters
to their legislators, things suffer.
It's important that
people have a public side
to their life and that
they do try to participate
in events that shape
us in a communal sense.
- When you were president
of the University of Iowa,
you also taught a course, what,
on conscience and public--
- I did.
It was a course that a colleague
and I taught together that was called
Individuals and Institutions.
We tried to read books and essays
about what happens when individuals
come in conflict with institutions.
We read some of the Greek tragedies.
We read Burke, we read de Tocqueville.
We read some Erickson, but life is really
about what happens when one's, often,
when one's conscience
is up against demands
from the public sector that
you behave differently.
- So what, in the end, will
enable, empower students
to develop these virtues in the four years
that they're an undergraduate?
Is it the kind of courses that they have?
The way that they're taught?
Or is it also the people they meet
in their own community of students?
- I think all of the above.
Certainly, who your fellow students are
is as important as anything,
and who your teachers are is important,
but I think reading is too.
My wife and I, a few weeks
ago, saw Hedda Gabler.
We've seen about half a dozen Ibsen plays
in the last five years, you know,
those are all kind of simplistic fights,
or The Enemy of the
People, between a doctor
who knows the water is unsafe
and a community that doesn't
want to have, announce it.
You have to decide, what do you do
as a person of conscience?
And it's not easy, and
if you become too rigid,
you just become kind of
uselessly moralistic,
but if you become too
lax, you may lose a sense
of who you are as a person.
I think literature helps students
think about those questions,
doesn't give them the answer,
but it helps them think.
- And partly what you're
trying to accomplish
in this laboratory of the
undergraduate education
is making students understand
that knowing that you
don't know is important.
- Oh boy, absolutely, yes.
I think any of us who have taught
certainly know that there comes a moment
when a student asks
something and you don't know,
and I was told by a senior colleague
my first year of teaching,
"You had better say
"I don't know, but I'll find out,
"because if you try to fake it,
they're going to catch you."
They're going to see that you're trying
to do it, but that's right.
We know so little, we know so little.
- Now this focus on the
liberal arts, as a leader,
you actually say somewhere
that you were mentored
by Martin Meyerson, Eliot
Stellar, and Vartan Gregorian,
who were all at Penn with you.
And you go on to say, "I came to realize
"that the true importance of holding
"a senior administrative position
"was the power to enunciate
the academy's central values
"and the responsibility to set forth
"the university's agenda."
And that is really what you've tried to do
in these various--
- That's what I've tried
to do, because my own
sense is that a president
is really the only
person in the institution
who has an opportunity to set the agenda
for debate within the
faculty and the student body.
He may not always prevail,
but he has the opportunity,
or she, to put items on the agenda
and ask that they be debated.
And, of course, being a president
is a rare privilege in terms
of access to the op-ed pages,
and to television shows,
and to things of that sort.
So that I've thought it
was always very important
for presidents to use that opportunity
to state those views that
they think are important.
- Now, in doing that,
there are two issues.
One is communication, which
you actually talk about
in one of your essays, and
I'm curious about that.
That is, the frustration
of having a vision,
being a craftsman enough to articulate
with your own words what that vision is,
but, on the one hand,
but on the other hand,
being a leader of a bureaucracy,
where an official statement
has to be filtered
through that bureaucracy.
Tell us about those, that tension
and how you reconcile that.
- Well, you know, every
president understands
that when he speaks publicly,
his words are circulated
to alumni, faculty, students,
the local community,
and that some of those
words are going to alienate.
And a president has a
responsibility to be cautious,
because you don't want to alienate people
on whom your institution greatly depends.
And so I think all of us feel frustrated
on some issues because of imbalance.
We conclude that it will
alienate more people
than you would like to alienate.
I think they will accept
you when you speak
on educational issues, although
I think affirmative action
is an example, that when
presidents do speak on that,
they sometimes do alienate
large sections of their alumni.
But I think one has to use the privilege
of that pulpit carefully, prudently,
because I think you do run
the risk of alienating people.
And I think all of us have had experience
with donors who call up and say,
"You know, that speech
did it for me, goodbye."
That happens.
- So in a way,
as a president, there
is an interesting play
between the sense from
your own personal life
of the vision that you
would like to realize
but then the political
realities of a university.
- That's right, there is indeed.
You mentioned Martin Meyerson,
who was president of the
University of Pennsylvania
as I was a young man moving
up the academic ladder.
One of the things that I
admired about President Meyerson
is that in his early years
as president of Penn,
he essentially said, You
here glow in the fact
that you're the best
university in Philadelphia,
and you glow in the fact
that you're a member
of the Ivy League, but until the day comes
when your PhDs are as
valued and sought after
by the Harvard and Yale faculties
as their PhDs are by ours,
we've got ground to cover.
I mean, he essentially came and said,
This place is a little too self-satisfied,
a little too smug, we need to be better.
And that had an electric effect.
People were a little upset,
but it had the proper
impact, the intended impact.
- When you came to Dartmouth, one of the,
part of the challenge for you, I think,
because Dartmouth, I believe,
had some difficulties before,
was to realize this liberal vision.
And you actually said in
your inaugural address,
"We must strengthen our attraction
"for those singular students
whose greatest pleasure
"may come not from the
camaraderie of classmates,
"but from the lonely
acts of writing poetry
"or mastering the cello or
solving mathematical riddles
"or translating Catullus."
That was a heroic statement
at that time, wasn't that?
- Well, I'll tell you, it,
the cello became my symbol
among the students, and
Catullus became an author
whose name they knew.
- I see.
- But I was concerned when
I looked at Dartmouth,
of course, seriously
before I accepted the job.
And what I was concerned
with was, I thought, a sense,
that there was too much emphasis
on well-rounded students.
The whole place had to be well-rounded.
And I wanted us to have some students
who were more, as I said,
"You can be so well rounded
"that you have no point at all."
Some students who had a
point, who had a focus,
who had achieved a lot and
meant to achieve a lot.
And so a part of my
mission there was to see
if we couldn't strengthen the student body
in those ways, and I hope we did.
- Give me a specific example of a program,
either at Iowa or at Dartmouth,
where you think this liberal arts vision
that you brought to the table mattered
in actually implementing a program.
- Well, for example,
we started at Dartmouth
a Presidential Scholars program,
where a student who had a
certain grade point average
could work 10 hours a week
for a faculty member as a colleague.
You could help do research,
you could edit manuscripts,
you could work in the laboratory.
You couldn't do gopher work.
You were not, you couldn't do xeroxing
that wasn't fair to the
students, or getting coffee,
but we tried to set up collaboration,
and the consequence of
that was that every year,
two or three papers would be published
with a faculty member's name,
maybe some graduate students,
and finally the undergraduate student.
But we very much wanted undergraduates
to be able to get a feel for what it was
to work with a faculty
member and to kinda be
at the frontiers of research,
and I think that mattered.
There was a lot of student
criticism at the first,
it was elitist and it was
special opportunities.
We've now reached the
point where it's now listed
along with the academic honors
in the commencement program,
and Presidential Scholars are listed
as a category of achievers.
So I've been very pleased at that.
- Now, you were at both Iowa,
a great public university,
and you were at Dartmouth,
a great private.
What is the difference?
Are there differences in the challenges
that you faced leading?
- Well, there are superficial differences,
which I think are not at the center
of what are the differences.
The superficial ones is that
Iowa was 30,000 students,
Dartmouth's a little better than 5,000.
Iowa was a public and one
dealt with a legislature,
Dartmouth is private, governed
by a Board of Trustees.
For me, the biggest difference
was that the value added
to a student's life
at Iowa was greater than at Dartmouth,
because the distance was greater.
Students came to that university
from small towns in Iowa,
never had left the state,
never been to Chicago,
never seen a play, never
been to a symphony,
maybe never seen a bookstore
in their hometowns.
And they came and they started
to read Plato and Aristotle,
and all of those things.
And they were set afire.
And they grew and grew and grew.
Dartmouth students were
from more affluent homes.
They'd had more higher quality
educational opportunities.
They came in at a much higher
point of sophistication.
And, of course, they grew too.
But I was really struck by the role
of the University of Iowa,
just opening up the lives
of kids who'd not had
that experience before.
- Was it, in this
public-private distinction,
compare dealing with
legislators for state budgets
with dealing with trustees and donors.
Is there a difference in
those two sets of tasks?
- There surely was not a
difference in dealing with donors.
There are people who
love their universities
and are philanthropic and want to give
and want to be helpful.
Dealing with legislators is different
because I just sensed the distance
between me and them was very great.
I was not of their type.
You know, these are legislators
who are elected by the people of Iowa,
and I was a very different
Eastern bred type of person.
It was quite different
with the Board of Trustees
at Dartmouth, who share
similar backgrounds
and you much more readily
belonged to that kind of group.
So it was a different experience at Iowa.
- So what then, what, if you
were writing a job description
for the title University President's,
what are the, educational
requirements aside,
what does it take to undertake the task
of leading great, either public or private
institutions of higher education?
- Well, I think it takes an appetite
to want to govern the institution.
And by that I mean, to
channel your own energies
and ultimately, professional fulfillment
through the institution.
You no longer channel your energies
through becoming a fixture
on the lecture circuit
or a writer of lots of books
or an attender of conferences.
You ought to be a person
who wants your glory
to come through the
strengthening of the institution,
so at the end of a period
of five or 10 or 15 years,
people will say, This is a better place
because he or she was president.
I do think you have to be a
person interested in ideas.
For myself, I think that by and large,
you need to be a person who's a scholar.
I don't think you can lead the faculty
if you haven't yourself been a scholar
and had the experience of
teaching and creating knowledge.
There are notable exceptions to that.
But I think as a general
rule, that's very important.
I think, too, you
somehow have to exemplify
something of a selflessness,
of a devotion to the place,
'cause you're asking other people,
all those people you work with,
all the vice presidents and deans,
to be devoted to the place.
And if you show less than full devotion,
or if you show cynicism in that,
it's much harder to motivate those people
to share your commitment to
making this a stronger place.
- One of the problems
that all universities
confronted during these periods
were the question of
excellence and equality.
Not necessarily saying
they're in conflict, but,
in other words to
ensuring greater equality,
ensuring greater diversity,
raised questions about the procedures
by which people would be admitted.
Tell us a little about your thoughts
on that set of problems
and how well universities
in general have weathered that process.
- Well, I think the process
of opening up universities
so there is greater access
and for a greater range
of students has been
a very successful one.
You look at most universities and I think
that affirmative action
has clearly worked.
It has given us more
interesting student bodies.
It's given us minority
graduates who will now take
a place in the professions.
I mean, when I look at what this country
is becoming and think of the possibility
that without affirmative action,
we would not be graduating people
of minority background who
would become the leaders
of this new country, in the professions,
and in education, and in
medicine, and in business.
I fear to think what the country
would have been like otherwise.
I mean, I think affirmative
action has been indispensable.
And I think all of us
find that one of the ways
that incoming students,
high school seniors,
judge the places they're looking at
is the degree of diversity that it has.
Students don't want to go to schools
that don't have sufficient diversity.
They recognize that they're inherently
more interesting places.
- And you actually say in your discussion
of what a liberal arts education should be
that the contribution that
is actually being made
by being exposed to different communities,
being exposed to different people
from different ethnic
and cultural backgrounds.
- Yes, indeed, I mean, it's interesting
that for, certainly, a generation
from World War Two onward,
universities understood
that geographic diversity was important,
and they went out of their
way to try to enroll students
from wider and wider sections
of the United States,
so that the notion that you learned
in better circumstances with students
who've had diverse upbringings
is not one that started with
the civil rights movement.
It's one that goes back
much earlier than that.
- Let's talk a little about
where universities are going,
in general, and one thing that strikes me,
I think it's fair to ask you,
is your commitment and
your powerful statement
of the importance of a
liberal arts education
a losing battle in the
face of the specialization
of the academic disciplines,
the emphasis in our society,
generally, about the importance
and priority that should be given
to the market and other factors?
- I don't know whether
it's a losing battle.
It's easy to look around
and conclude that it may be,
that pre-vocational education and college,
and professional education
at the college level,
is growing and growing, and
many, many parents want that.
But if people don't speak
up for the importance
of liberal education, we'll never know
if it might not be a losing battle.
We've certainly seen in the
national political scene
that ideas that seemed
like a losing battle
during the New Deal or the Great Society,
whatever, suddenly their
time seems to come,
and so my great hope is that enough of us
will keep alive the focus
on liberal education,
that the day may well come
when it's much more widely accepted.
- And what would a successful result be,
a kind of core curriculum
that exposed students
to more than what we
used to call Western Civ,
but rather the multiple
civilizations that, you know,
important to our understanding
of world cultures?
- I think, ultimately, a successful result
would be one that moved
professional education
to the graduate level, so
that undergraduate education
could be a liberal education,
and one could then take
a business, you know, one would then go
to a graduate school of business
or a graduate school of nursing,
or a graduate school of
accounting or journalism.
But that the undergraduate
years would be given over
to a liberal education.
- Is there a way that parents and students
who agree with what you're saying,
is there a report card
that they should give
to the university that they're looking at?
Is there a check-off list?
Is there a way of getting a handle
on what a school would look like
that embodies the vision
that you're talking about?
- I think it would look
like many, many universities
and colleges that exist today,
who would provide full opportunities
to major in English or
chemistry or psychology
or biology or Portuguese
literature, or whatever.
But I think parents are so concerned
that their children have the tools
for success in this
society that in a sense,
they constrict the kinds of things
students are willing to look at.
I had a young woman in
my office at Dartmouth
one year whose parents wanted
her to major in economics,
because they thought that had
great professional utility.
And she had, indeed, fallen in love
with Portuguese literature,
she just loved it.
And they could not understand why,
what was the attraction of
that and why you would ever
want to do that instead of economics.
It's in many ways the parents
that we have to talk to.
- And this, by the way, hearkens back
to these themes in your background,
that is, the themes of ambition
and a kind of a well developed
liberal vision of the world.
So in a way, I guess,
one lesson I'm drawing
from this conversation
is that part of the goal
of education is to empower students
to carefully and thoughtfully make those
kind of choices for themselves.
- Well, I think that's right.
I mean, people really
sometimes don't remember
that the college years,
you are still very young.
You are still, in a
sense, a post-adolescent.
You're trying to figure out who you are.
You are confused about
what career path to take.
You don't really fully know how
to estimate your own abilities.
You're influenced by peers.
It's a very confusing
time of life for students.
And I think it's important to expose them
to all these kinds of opportunities
that a liberal education does,
as they form more fully
and more conclusively
who it is they want to be.
- Now, in our environment today,
the implications of the technology that,
it's available, and you
actually beautifully stated
the problem yesterday in
your lecture, that is,
the capacity of technology
not to leave us alone.
The way that we can be
interrupted in those moments
of silence, reflection,
reading, and so on.
So this leads me to ask for your comments
on how we will navigate the future,
carrying in ourselves this vision,
which is both powerful
and beautifully stated,
about a liberal arts
way of dealing with life
and the world versus the
power, the attraction,
the seduction of all of
these new technologies.
- Well, the new technologies are,
of course, incredibly seductive
and attractive, as you say.
And I think right now we're obviously
in the first generation of
living with these technologies.
That means that people are just forever
made frantic by them.
People carry beepers and cell phones.
The minute they get home or to the office,
they get on the email to
see what's listed there.
Then they get on the answering machine
to see what's listed there.
On the other hand, they
bring you CDs and DVDs
and all kinds of wonderful things.
I hope we're gonna figure out,
finally, that we don't want a lifestyle
driven by these things.
I think, for example, with television,
adolescents aside, that
more and more adults
have figured out over two generations
that you watch television selectively.
You watch it for the
things that you truly want,
but it's not a narcotic for you,
and I hope we're gonna reach that age
with a lot of this new technology,
that we don't allow it to follow us
on vacation and follow us
into our home at night,
and forever pursue us, but
give us some time to ourselves.
- You speak of liberal arts
and a liberal arts education
as, really, a tool for life, in a way.
That might not be the best metaphor,
but a way to prepare yourself,
all through your life,
to deal with the ups and downs of life.
Now, I know that when you
were president of Dartmouth
you were stricken with cancer,
and you were public about that.
And you've written and said often
that your liberal arts training
helped you deal with the difficulties
of confronting that situation.
Tell us a little about that, how,
in this particular instance,
it really mattered what
you preached, so to speak.
- Well, in 1994 I was
stricken with cancer,
non-Hodgkin's lymphoma.
It of course, I was told
there was a good chance
of dealing with it
successfully with chemotherapy,
but it was probably a 50-50 chance.
Fortunately, it worked.
But that begins to make you think
that life is short, that
you're not invincible.
And then you begin to
ask, What matters to me?
Am I using my time properly?
Why am I letting other people
control so much of my time?
It makes you think
about your children who,
after all, are your most
important legacy on earth,
and it kind of makes you ask,
Have I completed my task
with them of passing on
the values I want them to hope and have
and to being an example and for them?
Have I become the kind
of father I wanna be?
Those things really make you
ask questions of that kind.
And I think the asking of the questions
begins to help you to try to answer them.
I, like everyone who is
stricken with cancer,
began by saying, Why me?
I mean, I'm a perfectly
nice person, why me?
And of course, you begin to realize
everybody says that, and a friend of mine
who happens to be a minister,
a Congregational minister,
said to me, "Why not you?
"Somebody has to be stricken
with this, so why not you?"
And I began to think about that.
But that's the whole
question of the arbitrariness
of the universe, it's the question of Job.
Why does God treat people,
some people in certain ways?
And I've had cancer twice since then
and I'm dealing with it still, now.
It makes me think about
it very, very seriously,
of particularly, how best to
be myself, if time is limited.
Whether it is, I don't know.
But, you know, a third
time makes you think
that it may, could be.
And it makes you see you don't want
to spend your time on trivial things.
You don't want to spend your time
on things that are mere duty,
if you've chosen them and
you can retreat from them.
You want to spend it on those things
that really matter to you.
- And did you turn to your books a lot?
That is, reading, was reading you found,
something even more useful?
- I found help, for one of the first books
I read is one of these books
that I mentioned earlier
that I read every two or three years,
'cause you can read it
in a long, long day.
And that's The Plague by
Camus, which, of course,
is about why does this
plague, this pestilence,
strike this city of Oran in Algeria?
And of course, nobody
can answer that question,
but they puzzle with it.
And that's, of course, what
you puzzle with, with cancer.
And you really ask yourself,
during that, I may have six months left.
I may have a year left.
What should I do with that time?
Why has this happened to me?
And people say to you glib things
that are well-meaning, like,
"You've really had rich life.
"You know, your work is done, in a way.
"I mean, you're so
fortunate, you didn't have,"
they say, "you didn't have a life
"where you failed at your career,
"or raised terrible kids,
or had a bad marriage.
"You know, your life in some sense,
"is a nice, complete package."
But nobody sees it about
themselves that way.
- One final question, sort of looking back
at this journey that you've been on,
students watching it, is
there one particular lesson
that you think that they might draw
from this intellectual
journey that you've taken?
- Well, you know, the lesson I really,
a lesson I really draw
is one that my father
always taught me, which is about
the importance of late bloomers.
My father had students in junior year
in high school who were C students,
and 30 years later they were the mayor
of Manchester, New Hampshire,
and they were college professors,
and they were physicians and lawyers.
We all mature at different rates.
And I think one of the things
a liberal education does
is to make you ready for the moment.
Make the ground ready for the moment
when the seed is prepared to drop.
I think students too often think,
if they're not a success in college,
they're a failure forever,
or if they're not a success
in a professional school, and I think
we all grow at different rates.
And there, the late bloomers are legion,
starting with Winston Churchill
and you can go through lists and lists
and lists, Harry Truman, one grows.
I hope students kind of understand
they're preparing themselves,
even if they're not quite
sure now where they're going.
- President Freedman, on
that very positive note,
thank you very much--
- A pleasure.
For being with us today, and telling us
this extraordinary journey
that you've been on,
both intellectually and as a leader
of great public institutions.
- Thank you very much.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(perky organ music)